Unsere welt ist anders als bisher angenommen es geht lediglich um ein kleines detail aber mit großen auswirkungen messen haben nämlich aktuell
gezeigt dass der offizielle wert des protonenradius wohl nicht korrekt ist
und das hat nicht nur für die physik sondern auch für viele weitere bereiche der wissenschaft
auswirkungen wie genau diese kleine revolution in der physik aufgenommen wird und welche folgen sich daraus
ergeben jetzt bei klick zum science fiction bei uns gibt's täglich spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal nur dann verpasst er nichts herzlich willkommen
Also erstens der offizielle standardwert für den radius eines protons liegt bei 0 8768
femto metern doch schon in den letzten jahren gab es immer mal wieder zweifel an den offiziellen werten des protons angefangen hatte alles im jahr
2010 hatte ein deutsches forschungsteam einen protonenradius
ermittelt der rund vier prozent unter dem standardwert lag dieses ergebnis erhielten sie mit hilfe der laserspektroskopie
einer proton million verbindung die studio sorgte für hitzige diskussionen
und erregte große unruhe in der physik welt viele fachleute gingen davon aus dass die messungen fehlerhaft waren andere
ließen aber auch zum ersten mal den gedanken zu dass der alte werth nicht korrekt sein könnte manche spekulierten sogar über eine bis dahin unbekannte
physikalische kraft dazu einer der studienautoren randolf pohl aus mainz nachdem
2010 unsere erste studie heraus gekommen war fürchtete ich dass sich ein altgedienter physiker melden und uns auf einen groben schnitzer
hinweisen würde aber die jahre sind vergangen und bis heute ist nichts dergleichen passiert
im gegenteil 2016 legte das forschungsteam nach und präsentierte eine weitere studie die ebenfalls kleinere werte für den protonenradius
nahelegte auch in diesem experiment wurde die laserspektroskopie
angewandt diesmal allerdings zur messung des dorian kerns einem wasserstoff isotope also eine variante des
wasserstoffs der atomkern von deuterium besteht lediglich aus einem neutron und einem proton und auch hier ergab sich die
rätselhafte diskrepanz die darauf schließen lässt dass eine
fundamentale größe der physik bisher falsch bestimmt worden war der radius des protons anfang des letzten jahres 2017
entdeckte ein forschungsteam vom max planck institut für kernphysik dann einen weiteren hinweis denn die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler ermittelten auch für die masse des protons
abweichungen vom standardwert das proton zeigte sich signifikant
leichter als bislang gedacht konkret zeigte sich der unterschied erst ab der neunten nachkommastelle
das ist zwar wenig aber spielt trotzdem für die physik eine riesenrolle denn nicht nur der
protonen radio sondern eben auch die proton masse haben in der physik eine
fundamentale bedeutung denn die neutronen bilden zusammen mit den protonen den atomkern somit gelten sie als fundamentale bausteine
aller materie die zahlreichen abweichenden messwerte machen physiker teams weltweit nervös denn auch
naturkonstanten wie etwa die so genannte
rietberg konstante sind von proton abhängig sie wird in der quantenmechanik
eingesetzt um die wellenlängen der spektrallinien von atomen zu bestimmen ein falscher offizieller standardwert ist demnach also fatal
somit war es höchste zeit die vorliegenden ergebnisse der drei messungen zu verifizieren
das hat das team vom max planck institut für quantenoptik in garching vor einiger zeit getan und zwar anhand des normalen
wasserstoffatoms hier konnte die messung nicht durch den austausch des elektrons durch das schwere
million verfälscht werden konkret analysierten die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler die spektrallinien des wasserstoffatoms und zwar bei zwei verschiedenen
energie übergängen zum einen bei einem so genannten 1 s 2 s übergang bei dem das elektron nach anregungen in den grundzustand
zurückfällt und dabei eine besonders dünne spektrallinien erzeugt das zweite experiment untersuchte den wechsel zwischen zwei
angeregten zuständen und zwar bei dem sogenannten 2 s 4 p
übergang hier wurden die atome durch einen laser zunächst angeregt und fielen dann in einen niedrigeren zustand zurück hierbei
sendeten sie photonen aus wodurch das forschungsteam rückschlüsse auf die protonen größe ziehen konnte das
ergebnis der beiden experimente ist mehr als eindeutig dass proton ist demnach kleiner als bisher angenommen
demnach liegt der protonenradius bei 0,8 35 kilometern und nicht bei den bislang offiziell
0,87 68 zentimetern es handelt sich hierbei also um werte die um bis zu fünf prozent unter den standardwert liegen und bei diesem ergebnis
kann man sich eigentlich sehr sehr sicher sein dazu einer der beteiligten forscher
thomas denn unsere messung ist fast so genau wie alle anderen bisherigen
experimente an regulärem wasserstoff zusammengenommen dazu kommt das team vom max planck institut hat die ermittelten daten sehr genau unter die lupe genommen
insgesamt drei jahre lang haben die wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler diese geprüft um eventuelle messfehler
auszuschließen dennoch
betont das
forschungsteam das andere methoden und weitere messung wichtig sein um wirklich auf nummer sicher zu gehen doch schon jetzt ist das
offizielle gremium für solche angelegenheiten ganz ohr und zwar ist die rede vom sogenannten
committee on data for science and technology
das standardwerte für
konstanten in der physik festlegt dazu ein sprecher wir werden dieses ergebnis sehr ernst nehmen
höchstwahrscheinlich wird der offizielle wert für den radius der protonen und somit auch die rietberg konstante schon sehr bald geändert
werden wenn ihr dazu und zu allen anderen themen nichts verpassen wollt dann endet meine handynummer auf whatsapp das geht einfach hier
dann schicke ich jedem von euch alle nachrichten mit dem link zum aktuellen video und zwar noch bevor sie abonnenten hier auf youtube
zu sehen bekommen
und ihr bekommt zur begrüßung ein kleines geschenk also hier draufklicken abo da lassen und auf jeden fall das video dafür auch noch draufklicken sehen
geheimnisvolles teilchen entdeckt bis dann
bleibt dran